في الاثناء قال زهيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
يا اير لابيد انه ينبغي على الوزراء بيني
جانس وجدي زنكو وجدعون ساعر لانسحاب من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه واضاف لابيت خلال
جلسه لكتله حزبه في الكنيست ان وزراء حزب
المعسكر الرسمي انضموا الى الحكومه برئاسه
نتنياهو ايمانا منهم بان ذلك سيخدم مصالح
اسرائيل لكن بقائهم يعني انهم يساهمون بما
يحدث في اشاره للتهجم على رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش واضاف لابيت في حسابه على منصه اكس
ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه ليست
مؤهله لقياده الحرب وان رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو غير مؤهل لقياده البلاد
وقال لابيد ان اسرائيل تحتاج لحكومه اخرى
ورئيس حكومه اخر اما باجراء انتخابات او
تشكيل حكومه
بديله